[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a dutch family film called eep
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins in a small town in the
netherlands a middle-aged man named war
lives with his wife tyne on an isolated
farm surrounded by open meadows war
likes to watch birds as a hobby he often
goes out in the woods with his
binoculars and a book about birds
one day war is bird watching when he
hears chirping noises nearby he goes to
check for the noise and finds a tiny
creature lying on the ground the
creature fits in the palm of his hand it
has a body and a face like a human
female but has wings for arms war looks
up at the sky to find her mother but
doesn't see anything such a strange
creature fascinates war so he brings her
home to show his wife
tyne is shocked to see the little girl
with wings war claims that the bird girl
might be an extremely rare species
because he has never read about such
creatures before he makes tyne remove
things from a basket on the dining table
and uses the basket as a crib for the
little girl
tyne suggests they contact the police
and hand the girl to them but war wants
to wait for the girl's parents to arrive
later we see tyne lovingly singing a
lullaby to her tyne and war have no kids
so they decide to take care of the
little girl as their own in case no one
comes to get her tyne dips a finger into
the water and feeds the little girl
at night they look at the sleeping child
in fascination while deciding her name
war wants to name her birdie but they
settle on the name v geltja the very
next day tyne buys a barbie doll that
comes with a changeable dress for
viguelcha and a tiny baby bottle to feed
her meanwhile war makes viguelcha a
larger stroller so they can take her
outside like a normal child but when
they put her on the stroller with a
blanket her wings are still visible so
tyne cuts war's sock and sews it into a
tiny poncho to hide vigouch's wings
the pancho works and the two take their
new daughter for a stroll in the town
while walking viguelcha makes noises
which tyne thinks is her trying to talk
but war believes she is more bird than
human so she might just be chirping
some women from the town are delighted
to see the new child war tells them that
they have just adopted vigalja when
asked why she is so tiny the two end the
conversation and leave
now a lot of time has passed and
viguelcha has gotten bigger she now
barely fits in the dining table basket
she has still not learned to talk and
only makes noises like a bird
one day tyne notices viguelcha trying to
fly as time goes by she starts acting
more like a bird than a human tyne is
distressed by the fact because she wants
her daughter to be more human despite
the fact that she is different tyne
tries to teach her to speak and eat with
her feet the two have made a tiny crib
for vegeta right beside their bed but
she jumps into their bed and sleeps in
between the couple when she is scared
one day tyne hears viguelcha saying the
word nini she thinks the girl is calling
her mama
from that day onwards she teaches her
the alphabet but viguelcha doesn't seem
to get it
she also notices viguelcha eating bugs
from the floor thinking that it is
normal for birds to eat bugs she serves
figuelcha worms on a plate and makes her
use her feet to eat it when viguelcha
cannot do it tyne is frustrated she
believes that viguelcha can only learn
manners by copying other people around
her
the following day she takes viguelcha to
a restaurant the gelcha sees pet birds
flapping their wings and does the same
afraid of being noticed tyne takes her
to a bathroom cubicle and asks her to
flap her wings there she waits outside
talking to a woman when viguelcha
doesn't come out after some time tyne
opens the door to see only her shoes she
gets a glimpse of viguelcha flying away
through the window and yells her name
but to no avail tyne goes back home
still worried for her daughter and tells
war about the disappearance they figure
that viguelcha mustn't have gone too far
so they make their way to town to look
for her
meanwhile we see viguelcha flying with a
group of birds having the best time of
her life she suddenly loses her balance
because of the wind and lands on
someone's bed through a skylight window
it turns out the room belongs to a
little girl named lotja lotja is
fascinated by vigiltj's wings and asks
her where she got them the two befriend
each other
lotja's father doesn't have time to play
with her so she finds solace in
viguelcha
elsewhere war and tine reach the town
and go to an airline information desk
when they do not get the information
they need they make their way to a hotel
to stay for the night meanwhile locha
pretends that she is also a bird and
takes viguelcha to a nearby tree
vigelcha easily climbs up and sleeps on
a branch while lochia naps on the lower
branch
warren tyne can't stay at a hotel
because all the rooms are booked they
somehow end up coming to the same tree
and sleeping underneath it
in the morning the couple meets locha
who tells them about a bird girl
sleeping on the upper branch but before
they can get to her viguelcha has
already flown away as the couple tries
to leave lucha follows them claiming
that she'll help them find viguelcha
they get on a bus while following a
flock of birds
tyne doesn't want to take locha with
them because she has a lot to handle but
the little girl claims that she can take
care of herself
viguelcha is flying with a flock of
birds but cannot keep up because of
their size
she lands on the roof of a church the
people see her and call the firefighters
to bring her down
when a firefighter reaches her he sees
her flying away from afar the people
assume the girl was taken away by eagles
the news makes the television and war
sees it too the couple then goes to the
firefighter's house and tries to tell
him about viguelcha being a bird he
almost doesn't believe them but tells
them that the bird went south he even
offers to help them find her
the group then makes their way south
meanwhile viguelcha reaches a tiny house
in the middle of nowhere she is sitting
at the window watching some birds when
they fly away she joins them but just
then gunshots are heard the group
follows the noise and locha finds
viguelcha at the bottom of the well
they use the fireman's gear to go down
the well and see that it is just
viguelcha's poncho
as night approaches they still haven't
found her so the group goes to a nearby
hotel to stay tyne has started treating
loch as her own daughter
at night locha notices a strange boy on
a tree outside her room she joins him
and the two have a nice chat
later at night the boy is sleeping on
his bed and hears a noise from under it
when he checks he is surprised to see
viguelcha sleeping under his bed he
remembers locha telling him about her so
he quickly goes to call her the two
returned to see that viguelcha is still
there all of them get under the bed and
sleep for the night lotia is happy to
have her friend back
in the morning the boy's mother comes to
clean his room the kids run to call
viguelch's parents but viguelcha has
flown away again before they can get to
her
now it is time for the group to continue
the pursuit however lucha doesn't want
to leave the boy he is the only friend
she has ever had and unlike viguelcha he
doesn't run away
tyne understands the little girl and
lets her stay the three of them then
continue their journey but the fireman
gets weak and decides to stay in a
nearby shed the other two end up in a
jungle where they cross a river
war has had enough of the pursuit and
tells time that they should rest for the
day they go back to the shed and sleep
at night the firefighter wakes up to a
chirping noise he sees viguelcha hanging
upside down on a tree she has injured
her wings while flying the firefighter
rescues her and dresses her wound when
viguelcha tries to fly again she is
successful
in the morning the firefighter tells
time and war about his encounter and
assures them that viguelcha is fine he
then separates from the couple who still
pursue their daughter they reach a beach
and civigelcia fly away towards the sea
they finally realize that she has grown
up and watch her fly away together
the couple plans to take a bus back home
but war hears a chirping noise before
getting on the bus
he runs toward the sea as time follows
behind they rescue a drowning viguelcha
from the water and bring her back
in the following scene the three are
back home having dinner the couple is
over the moon to have their daughter
back and celebrates by drinking
but the next morning they see her trying
to fly away through the window again
the couple feels bad for trying to limit
their daughter's freedom they finally
decide to let her go happily
warren tyne take her to the meadow she
was found in give her one last kiss and
let her fly away
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching